Game of Thrones fans may be committed to
memorizing every pivotal show scene
absorbing all of George RR Martin's book
details and reading and thus theories
online but there's one thing about the
show we might never get to experience
the original pilot thanks for the cash
shake ups that occurred after the first
version of this world building premiere
filmed in 2008 we already knew that this
unaired pilot existed somewhere
collecting dust and largely regarded
with disdain by its creators the series
started out with tums and merchants in
the role of Daenerys Targaryen
Jennifer Ellis Catelyn Stark and Jamie
Campbell Bower as nights Watchmen Waymar
voice but it wasn't the acting that the
showrunners took issue with there were
also some points of plot confusion that
rendered the first take of failure like
the fact that it wasn't clear Jamie and
Cersei Lannister were siblings Weiss
said of the first production watching
screenwriter Craig Mazin and others
watch the original pilot was one of the
most painful experiences of my life
Benioff agreed adding I was taking notes
and I had this yellow legal pad and I
just remembered writing in all caps
massive problem and it's all I could
think about the rest of the night as a
result they decided to shelve almost all
of the footage and reshoot the opening
episode which turned out to be a major
success and courted millions of fans
right away the unseen footage it seems
might never see the light of day Kit
Harington who of course portrays Jon
Snow our resident King in the north has
also recently weighed in on the
abandoned premiere effort telling the
Guardian they made a lot of mistakes it
didn't look right didn't feel rights
have nothing different about it like the
rest of us he's never seen in full but
indicated as 2008 Jon Snow was
clean-shaven with his long locks being a
simple wig
nevertheless the network didn't give up
after one poor pass decided to pick up
the series despite all the problems with
the pilot we got a chance to go back and
rewrite it when the team we assembled
for a second try at the show they leaned
more heavily into the adult content of
the series making it dirtier sexier
bloodier and more tangibly real suddenly
a story that came off as hokey on the
first try
became arresting to watch on screen none
of this was instantly alarming to
Harrington who had the good fortune of
landing Jon Snow at his first on-screen
role he said we didn't
it was going to go and we didn't know if
it was going to be any good but it was
HBO and it was American TV so it felt
like a huge deal even though he wasn't
part of the original screening gone so
wrong he has seen bits and pieces of the
original take because Weiss and Benioff
have used it before as blackmail
material sending him and flattering
screenshots from the episode and
threatening the release of the
amateurish first to work to keep him in
line
he said they say if I ever pissed them
off too much they're released on YouTube
every now and then they send me a screen
grab just as a threat given its rocky
start Game of Thrones feels more and
more like a miracle to have achieved
such a large scale and dedicated
audience investment but the idea that
there exists an episode of the show from
the same creative team that misses the
mark is also a pretty tantalizing notion
perhaps when the series is finally over
we'll finally get a chance to see what a
cornea less accomplished adaptation of
the fantasy sensation would have looked
like and we can all cringe right along
with the show's creators at long last
until then were much like Jon Snow you
know nothing Jon Snow thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to